- In the morning during the work week,
I usually wake up around 7:00 a.m.
and then slowly get myself ready for work.
I'm grateful for my wife who
usually prepares breakfast
for me in the morning.
She's a bit more of a
morning person than I am,
so she wakes up already a bit earlier,
gets everything ready,
and then often also joins
me for the breakfast.
And, of course, black coffee is very much
appreciated as well.
I then get myself ready, grab my bag,
and leave the house towards my work.
I live in Munich, and my
work is in Munich as well,
so it's a short commute that
I do every day to get there.
Usually I take the bicycle,
but recently it got stolen.
So at the moment, I take
the S-Bahn and the U-Bahn
to get to work, so public transit,
which takes me about 20
minutes every day to get there,
and then 20 minutes to get back as well.
I work for Building Radar,
which is a young property
technology company.
And our mission is to digitalize
the construction industry.
So as it's Monday morning,
I'm having a weekly check-in with my team.
I'm responsible for the
sales and the marketing team,
where everybody just
gives an update on what
their priorities for the week are,
just to create alignment in the team.
So, welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
Hope you're enjoying
following me around for a day.
I must say this day is
rather representative
of how it usually goes.
Here we are at the
office of Building Radar.
I started with this company
as a chief revenue
officer earlier this year.
And actually, if you're interested to join
the team as well,
Building Radar is currently
hiring for several positions.
You need to be based in Munich, though.
I will insert a link to
their career page below
in the video description.
In the meantime, I write some
emails and get some work done,
just in an effort to try to use the time
in between meetings as
efficiently as possible.
So as we are rather
young company, of course,
an occasionally the table
football match cannot be missing.
We do this quite regularly in the breaks,
and what I enjoy even more
is probably table tennis,
but most of the time used for meetings.
There are many lunch
options around the office.
So today we decided to
go for a Shavasana plate,
which I liked quite a lot.
We enjoyed it outside in the sun
before then heading back to the office.
And of course refreshing us
with a nice black coffee.
I love to drink lots of coffee.
So often just diluted with the
water just to make sure I do
not drink too much,
because otherwise I would be
able to drink several cups
every day, which is of
course not very healthy.
After lunch, I meet the marketing team.
We are currently discussing
some new lead nurturing
strategies we want to implement.
So we're sitting in front of
the PC because several members
are dialed in from the home office.
And then after this meeting,
I met together with another
colleague and we were discussing
some strategies for our events,
so webinars and other
events that we are planning
for the rest of the year
to get us on track on the marketing side.
After that I'm meeting
one of the co-founders
of Building Radar and we are
reviewing some high-level
business numbers on the
marketing and sales side,
and also discussing some
strategic initiatives
that will be now focus for
us over the next weeks.
After that it's time to get
home using public transit,
I usually then sit together
with my wife in the evenings
to have some dinner.
And then afterwards,
it's time to go back to the desk,
get some additional
emails and paperwork done.
The evenings is often also the time
I use for my Firm Learning work.
So indeed I was editing this
very video that I was filming
during the day.
So after that, I was going back
to answer even more emails,
many of them also from you,
but then it's time to call
it a day and just go to bed.
So hope this was interesting.
Please like if you enjoyed the
video and leave me a comment,
whether you want to see
more content like that,
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning
Good night.